there was a good old rule which bids us
never prophesy unless we know but all
the same when one cannot prophesy one
may guess especially if one is sure of
being out of the way when the Reckoning
comes therefore it is without anxiety
that I suggest a picture of this world a
hundred years hence Adventure as my
first guess that the world at that time
would be remarkable to one of our ghosts
not so much because it was so different
as because it was so similar
in the main the changes which we may
expect must be brought about by science
it is easier to bring about a
revolutionary scientific discovery such
as that of the X-ray than to alter in
the least degree the quality of emotion
that arises between a man and a maid
there will probably be many new rays in
2022 but the people whom they illumine
will be much the same from which the
reader May conclude that I do not expect
anything startling in the way of
scientific discovery that is not the
case I am convinced that in 2022 the
advancement of science will be amazing
but it will be nothing like so amazing
as is the present day in relation to a
hundred years ago a site of the world
today would surprise President Jefferson
much more I suspect than the world of
2022 would surprise the little girl who
sells candles at Grand Central Station
for Jefferson knew nothing of railroads
telegraphs telephones automobiles
airplanes gramophones movies radium
Etc he didn't even know about hot and
cold bathrooms the little girl at Grand
Central is a blase child to her these
things a commonplace the year 2022 would
have to produce something very startling
to interest her ghost
the sad thing about Discovery is that it
works towards its own Extinction and
that the more we discover the less there
is left
what was your family doing a hundred
years ago I've always been fascinated by
exploring history through the people
that lived it and that's why I've been
enjoying today's sponsor myheritage so
much a large amount of my family came
from Ireland and so there are some
fascinating stories going back over the
tumultuous 20th century and indeed as
soon as I typed in my father and
mother's name and birth dates into their
amazing smart match system it connected
my family tree with someone in Australia
which revealed waves of relatives I
never even knew about So within five
minutes of logging in my family tree
already had 72 people and that was just
on my mother's side here for example
there's a photo of one of my great great
uncles in the Army and here is an image
of my great great grandfather incredible
stuff and this is because my Heritage is
the number one family history service in
Europe it gives you the opportunity to
travel back in time along your Bloodline
with more than 16 billion records
available as a bonus you can color rise
old photos and even animate them
bringing your family history back to
life sign up for a 14-day free trial and
enjoy all the amazing features my
Heritage has to offer and if you decide
to continue your subscription you'll get
a 50 discount thanks to myheritage for
supporting history content on YouTube
[Music]
the 2022 will probably never see a wire
outlined against the sky it is
practically certain that wireless
telegraphy and wireless telephones will
have crushed the cable system long
before the century is done possibly two
power May travel through the air when
means are found to prevent enormous
voltages being suddenly discharged in
the wrong place
coal will not be exhausted but our
reserves will be seriously depleted and
so will those of oil one of the world
dangers a century hence will be a
shortage of fuel but it is likely by
that time that we will use power from
Tides from the Sun probably from radium
and other forms of radial energy while
it may also be that atomic energy is
harnessed if it is true that matter is
kept together by forces such as
electrons it is possible that we shall
know how to disperse matter so as to
release the electron as a force this
force would last as long as matter
therefore as long as the Earth itself
the movies will be more attractive as
long before 2022 they will have been
replaced by the kinaphone which now
exists only in the laboratory that is
the figures on the screen will not only
move but they will have their natural
colors and speak with ordinary voices
thus the stage as we know it today May
entirely disappear which does not mean
the Doom of art since the movie actress
of 2022 will not only need to know how
to smile but also how to talk
it is more interesting to ask ourselves
what will be the appearance of our
cities a hundred years hence to my mind
they will offer a mixed Outlook because
mankind never tears anything down
completely to build up something else it
erects the new while retaining the old
thus many buildings now standing will be
preserved it is conceivable that the
capital at Washington many of the
universities and churches will be
standing a hundred years hence and that
they will almost unaltered be preserved
by tradition
also many private dwellings Will Survive
and will be inhabited by individual
families I think that they will have
passed through the Cooperative stage
which may be expected 50 or 60 years
hence when the servant problem has
become completely unmanageable and when
private dwellings organize themselves to
engage staff to cook clean and mend for
groups that Cooperative stage will be
the last kick of the private mistress
who wants to retain in her household
some sort of slave in 2022 she would
have been Bent by circumstances but she
will have recovered her private dwelling
being served for seven hours a day by an
orderly the woman who becomes an orderly
will be as well paid as if she was a
stenographer will wear her own clothes
be called Miss belong to her Trade union
and work under Union rules naturally the
work of the household which is being
reduced day by day will in 2022 be a
great deal later I believe that most of
the cleaning required to day in a house
would have been done away with in the
first place Through The Disappearance of
coal in all places where electricity is
not made there will be no smoke perhaps
not even that of tobacco in the second
place I have a vision of Walls Furniture
and hangings made of more or less
compressed papaya mache bound with brass
or taping along the edges thus instead
of scrubbing its floors the year 2022
will unscrew the brass edges or unstitch
the tapes and peel off the dirty surface
of the floor or curtains then every year
a new floorboard will be laid one may
hope that standard chairs tables carpets
will be peeled in the same way similar
reforms will apply to cooking a great
deal of which will survive among
old-fashioned people but a great deal
more of which will probably be avoided
by the use of synthetic Foods it is
conceivable though not certain that in
2022 a complete Elite meal may be taken
in the shape of four pills this is not
entirely Visionary I'm convinced that
corned beef hash and pumpkin pie will
still exist but the pill lunch will be
by their side but at that time few
private dwellings will be built in their
stead will rise the community dwellings
where the majority of mankind will be
living they will probably be located in
Garden spaces and rise to 40 or 50
floors housing easily four or five
thousand families this is not
exaggerated since in one New York Hotel
today 3 000 people sleep every night it
would mean also that each block would
have a local authority of its own I
imagine these dwellings as affording one
room to each adult of the family and one
room for common use such cooking as then
exists will be conducted by the local
authority of the block which will also
undertake laundry mending cleaning and
provide a complete nursery for the
children of the tenants perhaps at that
time we shall have attained a dream
which I often nurse namely the city
roofed with glass
that City would be a complete unit with
accommodation for houses offices
factories and Open Spaces all this
carefully allocated the route would
completely do away with weather and
would maintain an even temperature to be
fixed by the taste of the period
artificial ventilation would suppress
wind as for the Open Spaces if the
temperature were warm they would exhibit
a continual show of flowers which would
be emancipated from winter and summer in
other words winter would not come
however long the descendants of Mr
Hutchinson might wait the family would
still exist even though it is not doing
very well today it is inconceivable that
some sort of feeling between parents and
children should not persist though I am
of course unable to tell what that
feeling will be I imagine that the link
will be thinner than it is today because
the child is likely to be taken over by
the state not only schooled but fed and
clad and at the end of its training
placed in a post suitable to its
abilities this may be affected by birth
control which in 2022 will be legal all
over the world there will be stages the
first results of birth control will be
to reduce the birth rate then the state
will step in as it does in France and
make it worth people's while to have
more children then the state will
discover that it has made things too
easy and that people are having children
recklessly finally some sort of balance
will establish itself between the state
demand for children and the national
Supply
foreign
ly the condition of the family will be
governed by the position of a woman
because woman is the family while man is
merely its supporter it is practically
certain that in 2022 nearly all women
would have discarded the idea that they
are primarily makers of men most fit
women will then be following an
individual career positions will be open
to them and a great many women will have
risen High the year 2022 will probably
see a large number of women in Congress
a great many on the judicial bench many
in Civil Service posts and perhaps some
in the president's cabinet but it is
unlikely that women will have achieved
equality with men cautious feminists
such as myself realize that things go
slowly and a brief hundred years will
not wipe out the effects on women of 30
000 Years of Slavery women will work
partly because they want to and partly
because they will be able to thus women
will pay their share in the upkeep of
Home and Family
the above suggestion of community
buildings where all the household work
will be done by professionals will
liberate to the average wife and enable
her out of her wages to pay her share of
the household work marriage will still
exist much as it is for mankind has an
inveterate taste for the institution but
divorce will probably be as easy
everywhere as it is now in Nevada in
view however of the improved position of
women and her earning power she will not
only cease to be entitled to alimony but
she will be expected after the divorce
to pay her share of the maintenance of
the children
it does not follow that scientifically
the year 2022 should fail to be amazing
I suspect that commercial flying will
have become entirely commonplace the
passenger steamer will survive on the
coasts but it would have disappeared on
the main routes and will have been
replaced by a flying convoys which
should cover the distance between London
and New York in about 12 hours as I am
anxious that the reader should not look
upon me as a Visionary I would point out
that in an airplane Collision which
happened recently a British passenger
plane was traveling at 180 miles an hour
which speed would have brought it across
the Atlantic in 18 hours it is therefore
quite conceivable that America may
become separated from Europe by only
eight hours the problem is mainly one of
artificial Heating and ventilation to
enable the aeronauts to survive the same
cause will affect the railroads which at
that time will probably have ceased to
carry passengers except for Suburban
traffic
railroads may continue to handle Freight
but it may be that even this will be
taken away from them by road traffic
because the automobile does not have to
carry the enormous overhead charges of
tracks certainly food males and all
light Goods will be taken over from the
railroads by Road trucks as for the
horse it will probably no longer be bred
in white countries
[Music]
as regards the politics of 2022 I should
expect the form of the state to be much
the same a few rearrangements may have
taken place on the lines of
self-determination for instance Austria
may have United with Germany the South
American republics may have Federated
but I do not believe there will be a
super State there will still be
republics and monarchies possibly in
2022 the Spanish Italian Dutch and
Norwegian kings may have fallen but for
a variety of reasons either lack of
advancement or something else we may
expect still Kings in Sweden Yugoslavia
Greece Romania and Great Britain on the
inside these states may have slightly
changed for their prevails a tendency to
socialization which has nothing to do
with socialism most of the European
governments are unconsciously
nationalizing a number of Industries and
this will go on one may therefore
presume that in 2022 Most states will
have nationalized Railways tele graphs
telephones canals docks Water Supplies
gas and electricity other Industries
will exist much as they do today but it
is likely that the state will be
inclined to control them to limit their
profits and to calibrate between them
and the workers we find a hint of this
in America at the moment in the
Anti-Trust acts a hundred years hence
the tendency will be much stronger
it is worth noting as an international
factor that purely National Industries
have almost disappeared and the work of
the world will be in the hands of
controlled combines governing the supply
of a commodity from China to Peru
unfortunately these international
relations through trade are not likely
to have perfected political conditions
there will still be War the wars of that
period may be a little less frequent
than they are today and may be limited
by Arrangements such as the Pacific
agreement the agreement between Canada
and the United States of America to
leave their Frontier on fortified but it
will still be there
I suspect that these wars to come will
be made beyond my conception by new
poisons inextinguishable flames and
smoke clouds in those Wars the airplane
bomb will seem as out of date as is
today the hatchet
War May ultimately disappear but this
lies beyond the limits of this article
and even Beyond those of the Mind
in regards of the United States in
particular it is likely that the country
will have come to a complete settlement
with a population of around
240 million the idea of north and south
east and west will have more or less
disappeared by that time the American
race will have taken so definite a form
that immigration will not affect it the
American from Key West and the American
from Seattle will be much the same kind
of person that is to say as regards race
but I feel that mentally the American of
2022 will have enormously changed he is
today the most enterprising creature in
the world and is driven by a continual
urge to make money that is because the
modern American lives in a country that
is only partly developed and where
immense wealth still lies ready for him
to make in 2022 that will be as finished
as it is in today's England American
Wealth will then be either developed or
known and all of it will belong to
somebody there will be no more
opportunity in America than there is in
England today those Americans will know
that it is practically certain that they
will die in much the same position as
the one in which they were born they
will have rebelled against long hours
the chances are that in 2022 few people
will work more than seven hours a day if
even that much the effect of this which
I am sure sounds regrettable to many of
my readers in my opinion will be good it
was essential that the American race
should be capable of intense labor and
intense ambition if it was to develop
the vast country but one result has been
haste and overworked all of which is bad
for the nerves
I think that she will be a happier
country than she is today the appeal of
wealth will be less because wealth will
be difficult to attain so those
Americans to come will be producing
literature infinitely more than they are
producing today it is not my business to
congratulate the future and I have no
desire to do so as it is impossible to
say a thing is good or bad all one can
say is that it exists but in case some
of my readers feel repulsion when they
contemplate my lunch pills or my
nationalized railroads to those I would
say that they are perhaps unduly anxious
the world takes care of itself it has
been doing so for hundreds of centuries
and it is still spinning the world will
take care of itself in 2022 that is its
Chief occupation and more than that I
feel convinced that though the world may
lose Graces it will develop other Graces
that on the whole and as time goes on
mankind grows more intelligent more
amiable and more honest
future will be difficult what does that
matter
so is the past difficult
difficulties did not prevent its turning
into a tolerable present
[Music]